الخميس الاسود كما اطلق عليه المحتجون
يشعل فرنسا قطع لطرقات اضرابات واغلاقات
ومظاهرات حاشده تنديدا طبعا بقانون
التقاعد الجديد الغضب على القانون ومن
اصدره يتزايد فاحتجاجات هذه الاحتجاجات في
فرنسا متواصله وزاد حجمها وعدد المشاركين
فيها في يوم اسماه الاعلام الفرنسي الخميس
الاسود السلطات الفرنسيه مشاهدينا
ولمواجهه الموجه التاسعه من الاحتجاجات
اتخذت تدابير امنيه اضافيه وارسلت خمسه
الاف من رجال الشرطه والدرك لاداء طبعا
مهامهم في العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس هذا
وكان قد اغلق المتظاهرون الطرق المؤديه
لمطار شاردي غول شمالي فرنسا وعلى اسره
اوسط السلطات الفرنسيه الركاب المسافرين
باعاده جدوله سفرهم سفرهم طبعا مع العلم
بان عدد الرحلات قد تم تخفيضه في معظم
المطارات الفرنسيه
بنحو الثلث